and a Fox News Alert as we reported
earlier tragic news tonight Lisa Marie
Presley she has passed away at the very
young age of 54 years of age here with
reaction co-host of the five Heraldo
Rivera Heraldo
I look at I look at her dad one of the
most gifted talented unbelievable
performers of all time it had to be very
hard for her growing up in his shadow
and we don't know I guess Cardiac Arrest
is the cause of death way too young for
my for my feelings your thoughts
oh it's just awful I send my condolences
to Priscilla her mom you know it is a
terrible tragedy you know the awful
gut-wrenching thing is that it was just
on Tuesday night at the Golden Globe she
was with her mom and they were
celebrating Austin Butler uh uh the guy
who played Elvis and that biopic they
were alive and and vibrant and opening
night and the excitement and all the
rest of it and a couple of days later
she's dead it is uh staggering
unexpected I guess
Lisa Marie had written extensively about
her problems with addiction you know I
think it would be uh well we'll withhold
withhold judgment until we hear the the
facts from the medical examiner but you
know it is awful here's a a little girl
who was born you know she was born into
a hurricane she later married so she's
the daughter of the king of rock and
roll she later marries Michael Jackson
the King of Pop uh you know my goodness
the King of Pop the king of rock and
roll and there's Lisa Marie trying to
find her way uh in the world her own son
killed himself eight years ago it was
just uh just awful I I feel for this
family uh Elvis was a magnificent
performer I I loved his music I I was
honored to meet him a couple of times
thanks to Jerry Weintraub my agent I
mean he was uh he was he was so special
and he loved her he named the airplane
Lisa Marie he flew her you know New York
Times tells the story he flew her up to
Idaho because she had never seen snow
before uh it was he he he he he loved
her and this is just uh just awful she
later married Nick Cage the the actor
and it's just just terrible terrible I I
feel feel for this family and Priscilla
our thoughts and prayers are with you
I'm so sorry this happened amen uh God
Rest our soul hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else